you probably realize this because guys
are quite stronger man before launch
into oppression it's always helpful to
say well before I give this a crack is
there anything I can do before I just
sort of like died straight here okay is
there anything that can help me
understand what's going on can I
manipulate us simplify this in any way
such I can get something that's gonna be
easier once I actually get to the
graphic okay now what I'm going to show
you is - significance but I actually
think it'd be helpful when we do the
graph and we add them together you've
got two parabolas here right but you've
got absolute values applied to both of
them
now we're not all that used to working
with absolute values and simplified them
too much but you should get a little
more familiar with them because they
come up everywhere you take square roots
and you're squaring things and that's
where absolute values really shine so
what I want you to remember is elegance
guy at the front right now when you take
the absolute value of a number like say
the absolute value 5
what that really means is what's the
distance of 5 from the origin and that's
just 5 okay but that's the same reason
why when you say the absolute value of
negative 5 you're doing more than just
taking away the negative ok you're
saying how far is negative 5 from the
origin and the answer is well it's also
5 ok so by definition you can say that a
value the absolute value of a number is
the same as the absolute value of
negative that number because they're
both the same distance from the origin
they just got opposite ways okay so I'm
going to take advantage of that over
here right this one's a little more
awkward than it actually is what you
really have is this ok you see what I've
done over on that left hand side that
parabola I mean the absolute value of 9
minus x squared that's the distance from
the origin right well I can flip it
around that's just the negative okay and
the distance from the origin remains the
same ok now the reason why that's
helpful is because that shows that these
two guys are really the same graph just
moved up and down a little bit okay
they've just been moved up and down and
that will actually be critically
important when we add these things
together ok so now if you haven't
already I'm gonna call this one migraine
one and I'm gonna make the
other one blue you're going to be
graphing this thing and they're just
going to be shifted vertically okay
because of the absolute value they will
hit down here and then bounce back off
but that's okay
do one do the other I'll give you a
minute to get those two brothers on give
you a bit of a chip try and make them
quite accurate okay if you've got a
template this will really help you
because look at these things it's the
same parabola they should share the same
gradient everywhere vertically right
they just up and down shifted into
different spots so if you've got a tip
that will help you do it because I'm
gonna give it a shot but I'm not that
optimistic give it a go and then let's
see what happens when we act let's go so
I hope you've got your components on
there again I talked about in case you
haven't heard me sort of getting implied
meaning by me just saying it I talked
about these as components they're the
bits that come together and the whole
thing is the composite that's what you
get when you've got everything all
considered right now we're thinking
about addition and subtraction of
ordinates again think about the easy
things before you get to the hard ones
so would anyone like me to have whatever
I suggest an easy point that we could
take how about x equals 0 it is
frequently an easy place to go right
so you got a fork it is your intercept
you've got 900 plus 9 13 okay so no big
deal right are there any other easy
points that I could go for yeah good so
anyway you've got roots right roots are
great because 0 plus anything is be
anything whatever the other value was ok
so if you've got a ruler there and I do
not actually know what I don't need to
measure all you need to do is take your
ruler and anyway you've got root do you
just say well ok helooo pretty cool to
you a bit I'm gonna yeah right you see
that's 0 plus something else yes and
then I've got another 0 here
so let's see how good my what was really
quick eh now remember I said do your
very best to do this accurately if you
haven't done it super accurate it's okay
but I'm going to make an argument from
this in a second okay I've been a point
up here right what's happening in
between here and this point that I know
right let's not just think an individual
ordinance now let's think about the
whole thing in how to behave okay yeah
yeah very good so think about think
about um what you know from geometrical
applications of calculus right in
between naught and to your green graph
is decreasing yes
the blue graph is also decreasing so if
you've got two things that are
decreasing and you add them together
then they'll be decreasing even faster
it's like it's like you know my kids
like fruit so I'll cut a mango for them
okay and if I give them one plate and
then put a tea it goes twice as fast it
just reads all I'm like seriously
I like hey where's my food that's it so
therefore write your picture this kind
of like their birth taking away from it
so yeah I'm coming down this great
distance and I'm doing it really fast
okay so therefore I'm getting something
okay so there's the first piece of the
graph by the way I hope you've caught on
to the fact of why I'm gonna get the
right hand side why am I even functions
add two even functions you get another
in funda okay now what's happening in
between here now based on the
awesomeness of my graph you have a
decent guess as to what's happening
right like look I start here and it's
some upper end here the question is what
am i doing in between now your intuition
ought to tell you well straight across
right but you can do better than
intuition remember I said to you these
graphs are the same graphs they are just
split vertically rights are not for
doing
shifted vertically okay so therefore
when I move this over
write this down McGrady on the green
should be exactly matching this upward
graded on the blue does that make sense
they're the same graph
they've just been flipped once been
flipped one's going down and one's going
up but they're going up at the same rate
going down is going up at the same rate
so when you put it together right it's
like someone filling up a bucket and
someone emptying it at exactly the same
speed right so the net gaining is zero
okay so you've got a horizontal line
there has to be a weird but again do you
remember we started off looking at the
sign X plus the absolute value of sign
it and it was exactly the same thing
when you get these absolute values if
they share the same gradient that will
exactly cancel out at certain points in
a doughnut okay
last piece here down just like I made
yogurt from zero to two I've got
decreasing must decreasing means really
decreasing well over here on the right
hand side you'd say increasing plus
increasing is really really increasing
okay so that's important by the way
because that means when I draw this new
gradient up it has to be steeper than
both of these right so that's why it's
gonna well there you go it's pretty
pretty steep right um how I've been a
little thoughtful
I might have drawn the vertical scale
this a bit more compressed so that I
don't get you know Tara Lindquist is
drawing a vertical line cuz it's not a
medical line but on my scale it looks
pretty close to it okay that's it that's
all the behavior right over here on the
right is no more changes it just they
both keep on climbing so the black line
will also keep on cutting I've got
everything on the right now I can
reflect across because of the evenness
of my functions okay so I guess
and there's the Suncoast to focuses not
difficult at all if you think about it
carefully and logically fact it's kind
of um it's kind of got a beauty of its
own when you think about all of the
symmetry that we took advantage on in
order to graph it